all right guys
bang bang i've got a very very special
episode for you today
uh mckenzie is here i constantly get
people who ask me to
come on the podcast who uh want to hear
from
kind of an everyday person not somebody
who works in wall street or in finance
somebody who doesn't spend all day as a
professional investor
but rather somebody who has come across
bitcoin
as part of what they do on a day-to-day
basis and so i thought it'd be great to
have mckenzie come on and talk about
that so thank you so much for taking the
time to uh to do this sir
absolutely thanks for having me this is
a unbelievable uh
uh experience for me for sure so let's
start just with
uh a little bit of background on you and
your family so that people kind of
understand the perspective that you're
coming from where were you born and kind
of
what have you done in your career until
today sure so uh
yeah i was born uh actually in the lower
mainland of
british columbia surrey bc
most of my family's from around that
area
so basically my parents moved to
vancouver island which is a
small island off the west coast of
canada
and it would have been 89. i was a year
old when we moved here
my parents came over for a holiday my
they fell in love with it right away my
dad's
been a career flooring installer he
found work immediately
never went back and from then uh yeah
we we uh we had a lot of family follow
us over
um as far as the work end of things
um like i say
my entire family has been in the
flooring industry
um it's something going through high
school growing up
i never thought i'd be getting into um
you know when you're
surrounded by it you're like um i i
might want to try something else but
then uh
once i got married had kids i started to
realize
just how uh one profitable and
and how good i was at it i've been
installing flooring with my dad since i
was 14 years old that's basically when i
started screwing up in school and
he made me go to work with him instead
of going to the school dance
um so yeah it's uh it's been
i've had through my 20s a lot of
different uh employment opportunities
got to try a lot of different things
um young family been a father since i
was 21 years old
and uh but every one of those jobs
it's uh it's benefited me
in some aspect of what i'm doing now and
uh yeah it's been really cool to see
those different skill sets all come
together to where i am now
absolutely and so how old are you now um
and then how many children do you have
i'm 32 and i have two girls um
one four and 110. awesome and so
when i think about you you know i think
of you as kind of the quintessential
um you know well in america we would
call kind of the american story right
but but obviously being in canada
uh of a hard worker who uh has a young
family
and uh you basically are doing
everything that you're supposed to be
doing in order to build
a great life for your family for your
daughters
uh and kind of accomplish the goals that
uh you set out for yourself is that fair
to say
absolutely at least that's what i'm
trying to do
i think you're doing just fine my friend
so one of the things as we were talking
beforehand
um and kind of preparing for this that i
found very fascinating
is the approach that you take right most
of the jobs that you've held
uh have to do with some sort of physical
labor and the creation
of um or the production of something in
the in the physical world so you're not
a software engineer you're not working
at a tech startup right
you're doing flooring or roofing and
kind of more construction driven jobs
um but that industry has some amazing
people
and it has a lot of people who people
have bad experiences with i think
your approach to how you service clients
and the people you work with is really
unique and will play into the value that
you see in bitcoin
but just talk to me a little bit about
kind of the perspective that you have
um and that you take to work every day
in terms of the value
and how you work with those clients
absolutely so
my biggest frustration being in the
construction industry
is going into someone's home
and seeing contractors
treating the client as if they're doing
them some kind of favor
i don't care how busy it is how how
long you've been in the industry
or frankly how the client's treating you
they are doing you a favor
they are hiring you and they are
trusting you and your expertise to do
the best job possible
um so i guess my
my view uh and how i communicate with my
clients i don't
i guess i'm a little more close with
them i i
i treat them as if they say they were
saying my parents
um i don't want them to uh
i don't want them to feel like i am
in there just to make make my buck and
get out
um so yeah a big thing is
i understand how hard a lot of small
town people people all over the place
work for their dollar
i know how hard i work for my dollar and
i want to give them the best value i
possibly can
and it doesn't mean i can't be friendly
along the way and
especially in a small i live in a town
of just under forty thousand
everybody knows everybody my i
basically don't advertise everything's
word of mouth
i don't have decals on my truck i don't
do any of that it's just
word of mouth being conscientious of
the client and making sure that like i
say
i'm giving them the best value for their
dollar yeah and
you specifically mentioned one thing
that i think is really important which
is this idea of
outside of major metros there's this
understanding
uh and belief that people work hard for
their money right
these are people who are putting in long
hours
hard hours in comparison to a lot of
kind of
major metros or software type businesses
and therefore when
you go when you perform a service you
essentially are saying hey look i need
to provide
value equivalent to or over the amount
of money
that they're giving me because i know
they worked hard for it and so i'm going
to work hard for them to then give it to
me is that kind of a fair way
uh to describe the approach you take
absolutely and
i can't even say i know my experience is
in a small town but i can't say that i
wouldn't approach it the same way
um outside it's just it's it's what i
expect from someone
when uh i'm hiring them i expect them to
uh
to really respect the fact that
i am i'm providing you with a living
while you're working for me and to me
that is
everything um you know that's how i
support my family so
yeah absolutely that makes sense and so
you are probably uh not very high on the
list that most people would think of as
somebody who
um comes across bitcoin becomes uh a
believer in bitcoin
uses bitcoin uh invest in bitcoin etc
let's start with just like when was the
first time you ever heard about bitcoin
and kind of what did you think when you
heard about it
sure so uh first time i ever heard about
it i was at my buddy's house
uh i think they were watching football
or something
placing some bets on the game and one of
my buddies who's a software engineer
brings up ethereum and bitcoin
and how i think i think they were
trading
ethereum was around 14 at the time and
bitcoin
i maybe a thousand uh
so i just remember these guys being like
i'm up 15 grand this week like this is
insane
so of course my first inclination is not
what is it it's how am i going to make
money here
um it's probably the might be the worst
way to
to go about it but really that
that 2017 uh 2016-2017 bull run
that started i made a lot of money
and at the same time lost a lot of money
i did
uh luckily i was about break even at the
end of it but you see these huge gains
really quickly and it's just like
gambling you don't you don't
register that that is real money
and you think that this is going to go
on forever it's that whole euphoria that
everybody talks about and it's
so real so the difference is at the end
of the bull run
when everything was said and done i
backed away out of the markets for a bit
and just went there's something here
i i you know let's see let's see what it
was
i was really getting myself into and
from there it's been three or four years
of just
picking away trying to understand
understand uh the sound money uh
theory and all all these different
things that that uh
are going to help me keep the money i
earn
and uh yeah just have more for the
future i i've never invested i've never
invested a penny before
bitcoin came along and it just
opened my eyes to a whole the whole
financial realm
yeah and so what's interesting to me
about this is is there's a couple of
data points that
uh i think people intuitively believe
are true
uh but hearing them from uh somebody in
your position
is uh really powerful right so the first
is uh
just the the raw honesty from you of
like
hey i came to get rich right the the
price appreciation
got my attention and therefore i thought
that i could make a bunch of money
really fast
i actually think that that is a lot if
not almost
everybody who initially comes across uh
bitcoin specifically
in these assets right it is this
understanding of like kind of the number
goes up
right but then what ends up happening
whether it's because of a market crash
time spent you know curiosity whatever
is eventually
you start to understand more about what
is the history of money what is sound
money why is it
important how can it protect my wealth
so there's this saying
i think it's uh my buddy uh marty bent
who who first said it that's like
you come for the money and then you stay
for the money right you come to make
money
but then you eventually stay for the
sound money right and it sounds like
that was
very much kind of your experience is
that accurate
absolutely it is and the hardest thing
to do
once you have that realization is
convince your family that this is the
right
thing to do because it is not well
understood
um like my parents i you know i've been
talking
at them for the last four years about
bitcoin
and not really being able to explain it
properly
uh like i say i'm a tile setter i am not
a financial advisor
um but then i start coming across
literature that
really helps out the bitcoin standard i
mean
that was that was my foundation
uh just understanding um
all of these different monetary systems
and why they failed they failed for the
same reason every single time
and and then you go down further down
the path and you're
the sovereign individual and the fourth
turning
and you try not to get too apocalyptic
about everything because
uh you know you gotta wake up and get
out of bed every day
but um it's uh
like i say it's just been an
unbelievable
journey um just
figuring out step by step why
this is happening um because it is it's
hard to believe
uh for a lot of people that this is this
is
the new standard this is where we're
going and
when i know guys like you and me see it
but uh it's so weird to be one of those
people when the rest of the world is
just catching on
absolutely and so let's start with um
you know
you make kind of the initial investment
in bitcoin price goes up price goes down
um
you also it sounds like uh ether and
maybe others
um and as you kind of go on the
education journey so take away the price
for a second as you go on that education
journey
i'm assuming that you're talking about
it with your wife with your parents like
what are they saying are they like
you're absolutely insane and like stay
away from me
and stay away from that stuff or are
they more open-minded like what's kind
of the reaction as you're going down the
rabbit hole
well four years ago i was working uh
doing
sales and flooring i i thought i'd give
that a shot
not my gig i found that out pretty quick
but i remember
trying to explain it like with this very
basic understanding of what bitcoin is
to my boss at the time
and he's sitting there staring at me and
i don't think it was
probably the best play he's like okay if
this guy doesn't understand that uh
we want canadian dollars not bitcoin
that might be an issue so then
then i move on to my parents um
and it's not that they didn't understand
but
they're reaching retirement age and this
is
especially then the very volatile high
risk
asset that maybe they don't want to get
into
um so and then and and then other
other family members i remember being uh
on a
family reunion sitting on a lake in a
boat explaining to my dad's cousin
talking about bitcoin and my best friend
sitting there
and uh yeah it's just it
you do your best but uh all you
all i can do is direct them to the null
the the the different areas where i
learned and
pass that knowledge on to them that way
because i'm not the right guy to be
to be spelling and then as far as my
wife goes
she is the best she is just she trusts
that uh i know what i'm talking about
and that i have the best interest
of the family um i tried to get her to
listen to
the bitcoin standard and she ended up
using it as a meditation to fall asleep
so
that is amazing yeah so talk a little
bit uh and obviously don't disclose kind
of numbers and stuff but
when you think of investing in bitcoin
or holding bitcoin
um is this something where you're
thinking of it as like a portfolio
and you kind of uh invest then when they
want to sell it is it something where
you say no i want to kind of save and
use bitcoin as a savings technology
like how do you think about it and then
how do you think about how much canadian
dollars to hold versus bitcoin versus
maybe other assets
sure well at this point um
the way the world is right now it's
been really difficult for me not to go
all in on bitcoin
um especially in canada here
um this covid thing has
obviously nuked to the country
we have had a lot of support and
stimulus from the government which is
good and bad there's different ways of
looking at it but the bottom line is
i believe we spent 57 of our gdp this uh
this year and
we're getting all of these different
benefits whether it be
um the cerb 1200 every two weeks or
or the business loans where uh you
borrow thirty thousand ten thousands
forgivable
um though that all needs to get paid
from somewhere
um and it's uh that's why i've
personally i i've been fortunate um with
everybody staying at home they stare at
their walls and want tile on them
apparently so i i i can't
really uh i can't complain in that
respect but
um it's funny how that works right oh
yeah everyone sits around
at home and says hey i actually need
some some improvements around here but
i'm gonna sit here all day
absolutely and it's baffling to me it's
like and it's the same with uh
interest rates dropping uh our real
estate values have shot through the roof
and it's like is real estate really
appreciating that much
or are people just getting more access
to
funds that well it's not my place to say
whether or not they should be borrowing
but
it's there um tax deferrals
uh mortgage deferrals all these
different things it's like we're just
kicking the can down the road that's all
that's happening here
and uh yeah it's uh it's an intimidating
prospect
absolutely and it's pretty crazy too to
think you know one
of uh you take that mentality that you
have of like everyone works hard for
their money and therefore i want to
provide value
um but also too it sounds like you've
got this idea around
but i work hard for my money as well and
i want to protect it right
and that's kind of when you talk about
the the national debt and a lot of these
issues
um it sounds like really for you bitcoin
is much more a way to protect wealth
than it is as like a speculative asset
or anything like that
yeah i i if i'm being completely honest
it's both for me right now because
of where we are um in bitcoin's growth
um yeah obviously i see the upside of it
um but in the same breath if we were
10 15 years down the road and bitcoin
was stable
and we were in the same position i'd
still be there because
like i say this uh
where you sell a house for 450 000
a year ago and now it's worth uh you
know
570 000 that's not that's insane
and that's not uh it's the same you go
and buy
you know a case of coke or something and
that was four dollars last year and it's
7.99 this year it's happening
everywhere so so i i'd be i'd be
a liar if i was saying i'm not here for
the price discovery as well
that's a big part of it but uh no the
the stability
when you can say i'm confident in the
stability of bitcoin
even with the volatile uh price swings
that are going on
that's saying something um i'm not
against paying taxes or anything like
that
i just uh i'm very much for
not having my money taken when it
doesn't need to be
yeah and what's so interesting to me is
um
you know i think of this as like uh you
can be described as a hard-working
canadian
who uh simply wants to provide a life
for their family
right i mean at the core of it everyone
wants to
have enough resources to live the life
that they want to live and they want to
be happy
right and i think that uh what is
fascinating to me
uh and i think that you're not alone in
this is um
something like bitcoin can pull so many
people in and really open
their eyes to kind of the macro economic
world to the financial
investing world right like it almost
sounds like over the last three or four
years
you've gotten a crash course and a lot
of different topics that
have a very material impact on you your
family your finances
uh but aren't necessarily taught in
school in a way that people pay
attention
or learn correct absolutely and and
that's just the thing
bitcoin could disappear tomorrow and i
would still be better off for it
existing for the time it did
um like i say it just brought so much
clarity and
no it's not taught in schools um
you know i'm 30 years old and i went
through my 20s
not being aware of any of this and you
know hindsight's 20 20.
you can't go back but but you just you
just go man
some of those choices i made for these
small
short-term gains these short-term
happiness um could have
developed into something so much bigger
had i just understood that
that value proposition for long-term
savings
yeah and we haven't talked about this
before so so i'm actually curious
uh to your answer but do you feel like
um understanding of bitcoin the macro
environment
inflation a lot of kind of things we've
talked about has that
changed your spending patterns or your
saving patterns
like how i i guess there's one part
that's like knowledge
the other is behavior change what if any
behaviors have changed that you think
are noticeable
uh for me in particular massive changes
um
okay yeah um in what way
well well we uprooted ourselves in
probably the biggest way you can
sold our home to pay down all the debt
that we possibly could
um so basically we're at net zero and
yeah i mean i wouldn't have thought of
doing that two years ago
you just think that sitting in your home
and allowing
real estate values to inflate like
that's your
retirement at the end of it and if you
can pull some money and maybe get a
investment property and build that way
that's one way
but i've worked 19-hour days
and done that you know
just grinding grinding day after day to
make the bills get paid at the end of
the month
and when i with my kids i'm just like
that is not a way i want to live my life
i have no energy when i get home i i
you know i'm 32 and i don't have energy
to play with my kids what's wrong with
that picture i had this silly idea in my
head that
if i wasn't stressed and exhausted i
wasn't working hard enough
and that's not true that it that that is
the root of the problem and it's the
same thing with money
you don't have to you know if you just
let it do its work for you then
it takes a lot of the stress away
it is uh it is so true right in terms of
one uh kudos to you for learning this
stuff
to uh having the courage and conviction
to act right i mean you know
i say it all the time but uh getting out
of debt can be one of the most freeing
exercises that you can do and so being
able to do that alone
um is a big thing but i think that the
third thing you said there that is
um so true and and frankly people are
taught the opposite
is to put the money to work for you
right most people are told
save save save and what they don't
realize is based on their income and
their expenses
there's just not enough money to save to
ever actually kind of get out of the rat
race
right what you got to do is you got to
be able to have a little bit of money
you know as a rainy day
uh but then you got to be able to invest
everything else and grow it and have it
grow
faster than inflation so that you're not
just having to trade your
hours for dollars right instead you can
actually use the investments to help
build wealth and it sounds like you that
kind of really hit home for you and
change your behavior
absolutely and and i think
again early 30s with a bad sciatic nerve
i can't do this forever it's uh it's not
a long term
play for me um the construction industry
and uh yeah it's 40
45 50. it's not far off so it's going to
come a lot quicker than i know
so uh yeah just like i say getting
prepared for that
for sure and then so the last thing i
want to talk about is uh is kind of
spending habits right so one of the
things that i personally have seen is
i've started to almost like in my head
denominate things
in satoshis or in bitcoin so uh you know
in uh 2019 january 2019
uh my wife you know wanted to buy a
couch and i was calculating like how
many bitcoin that would be right now is
like no we don't need a couch
and so you know that's kind of like an
extreme example but do you see
uh kind of changes not only on the
investing side but also in the spending
habits as well
absolutely um
you know it's kind of tough in certain
ways like
i look at uh the position we're in now
um the the thing the important things
are like uh my daughter just started an
outdoor
outdoor uh preschool program
that for better or worse that was a
stressful
thing for me to know that we're spending
that extra money every month
of course i want that for my kids but
it's still money out the door which
means i'm not home
um and so yeah that kind of stuff is a
lot easier to do but then the
the trivial um
little knick-knacky things like you say
your couch i i
we don't need it we just don't need it
right now give us i keep on telling my
wife we're not even looking at houses
right now
give me some time let's see where this
goes we we
we don't need to rush anything so yeah
and what's interesting to you
uh kind of your perspective because i
don't think a lot of people do this
whether it's because they they don't get
paid hourly
or it's not kind of more manual type
work but
you literally are making a connection
between uh
if your daughter goes to preschool it's
x dollars which means you've got to work
y
hours and therefore you can make a
direct kind of connection between a
decision you make on the spending side
with an uh kind of energy output for you
right
like there's a direct link between i'm
going to have to work x number of more
hours in order to pay for this
and so i think that that direct linkage
makes it much actually clearer for you
uh to make those decisions right for
some people that's harder for them to do
they actually don't know how much money
they get paid per hour
because they're on a salary or something
like that for you that connection
being so clear probably makes it a much
uh
at least clearer decision not
necessarily easier but but just
much easier to evaluate it's
unbelievably clear to me and
and it's something that i've had to
explain uh
it's something my wife and i have
discussed because um
she she's at home with the kids and like
i say
every dollar i make is i i equate it you
equate things to satoshi's i equate it
to a minute spent with
with uh my kids um so
yeah absolutely it's i
don't look at uh i don't look at houses
i don't look at trucks i don't look at
any of those
those different objects in the world
as uh what i'm working towards it's all
about
time with my kids if i can make it to
some point my goal is
at some point i can make it to
my kids still living at home and me
being able to work a
four four-day work week and have three
days for them that's still
that's still crazy to me that we spend
more time at work than we do
with our family even in the best case so
yeah absolutely that is uh
that is the value proposition for me and
i don't know if you've ever heard of of
this uh kind of framing in the bitcoin
world but basically the whole idea
is that bitcoin is time right and and
essentially what you're describing is
exactly that right is there's a direct
trade-off between
wealth and time and the less wealth you
have
the more time you have to spend but the
more wealth you have the less time you
have to spend
uh kind of doing things you might not
want to do right so your point of um i
love the idea of you having measurable
goals right
i need i know i need to get to x numbers
so then i can spend four days working
three days with my kids like a lot of
people i think have a dream
right which is hey i want to spend more
time with my kids
okay that's great how are you gonna get
there well by you setting kind of a
measurable goal right
it's pretty trackable uh and something
tells me that uh that you're pretty
driven guys so that you'll you'll likely
get there as well
yeah i i sure hope so i hope so for the
sake of my kids because you only get to
see them grow up once
and uh man it happens fast everybody
says it
but it's unbelievable absolutely
all right before i let you go uh i
always ask people the same two questions
uh for you what is the most important
book that you've ever read
okay so uh full disclosure i don't read
pomp
i haven't since high school um
audible is my friend okay audible so you
listen to books don't read them
well i i'm 10 hours a day working by
myself
and that's why podcasts all these
different things that's my knowledge i
get to sit there and and just listen
and uh what's the best what's the best
one you've listened to recently
so recently i'm gonna say the only
reason i'm not saying the bitcoin
standard is because the fourth turning
everything that's happening right now is
blowing my mind
like every time i i i was explaining we
watched a social dilemma with my
daughter
the other day the 10 year old because
she's starting to get to that age
and uh she uh
i was explaining to her how as
negative as it looks the fact that we're
realizing all this stuff and we're
seeing the bad in it
that's good news i i see a turnaround
coming and i can
see a world where if we play things
right my daughter
never will experience that that draw
of social media and all those negative
effects and
maybe only benefit from the tools uh in
it so
yeah i like to say the fourth turning i
always explain to her how
her generation is the hero generation
and they're gonna pull us from all this
nonsense online i i love that
second question is more fun aliens are
you a believer or non-believer
yeah again being a listener of the
podcast i got some time to really think
about this and i didn't want to have the
same
answer as everybody base
answer is absolutely the reasoning for
that is i hate to keep bringing up my
kids but
i you stare at your kids for long enough
and you try and figure out how
this person came to be how how
how this all came in into
fruition and you go yeah i don't have
the answer
and i'd be ignorant to say that
there isn't life elsewhere i'm i'm i'm
all for believing
whatever you want to tell me when it
comes to that
i love that the parents usually don't
like talking about that but the idea of
like
hey i made this thing uh every single
one of my friends who's had a kid who's
still got a young kid is just you know
they all go through that so i don't
think that you're alone there yeah it's
nuts
awesome man well listen you could ask me
one question to finish up what do you
got for me
okay um i guess again selfish question
i slid into your dms there out of
nowhere you don't know me
i don't have much of a twitter presence
i'm purely there to read
content and maybe throw a meme
or a gif in it every once in a while um
but why why why did you decide that i
was the guy you say you have
so many people bugging you why was i the
guy
yeah uh i don't know uh is a short
answer
uh no so for those that don't have the
context
uh over the last i don't know year or so
uh on numerous occasions people have
reached out to me and been like hey
uh you should basically bring on uh kind
of an everyday bitcoin right somebody
who
doesn't exist in the financial world uh
doesn't kind of spend all day doing this
uh they've got kind of what most people
consider a quote-unquote a normal job
but they have either fallen down the
rabbit hole or something
and usually they position it as um
you know they want to come on the
podcast they want to
discuss maybe it's a token that they're
invested in or a project that they're
really excited about like there's always
some angle that they want to capture
i think when you messaged me it was just
like hey this is crazy but like
i'm just a normal dude uh if you want
like i'll come talk about it
and i've been thinking like i need to do
that at some point for whatever reason
when i read your message i was like oh
this is somebody who has like no agenda
isn't coming on to like pitch anything
or do anything crazy
uh and the thing that i love is uh kind
of when you articulated like here's my
work history here's my family like
it was just very i think um kind of
down the fairway of like i actually
think there's more people like you
uh who are into bitcoin or in the
bitcoin community than people realize
and
while i think a lot of like the media
attention and all of that is
uh kind of the robin hood you know
trading bros like everyone's going you
know yolo long with 100x
uh you know leverage like sure there's
people like that
but i think when you look at bitcoin
specifically
uh your story is very similar
but it's not just people in canada it's
not just people in the united states
your story is the same story that can be
told
you know in pretty much every country in
the world uh and that's kind of the
beauty of bitcoin
right is that this is a asset that
everyone from
you know larry fink who's the founder of
the largest asset manager blackrock in
the world
all the way to you me and
millions of other kind of everyday
people bitcoin can
serve the purpose that we want and to me
you know when i just read the message i
was like all right
i got to do it here's the guy uh i told
you send me an email
because i had to make sure that you
weren't you know crazy and gonna come on
and say some wild stuff
uh but then i thought you were gonna ask
me for a lot more information than you
did if i'm being honest
no it was just like look just just tell
me kind of your story right
and you put together a great email and
it's just like hey like here it is and
again it wasn't a pitch about anything
or whatever and i said look let's do it
and and i think that kind of as we've
talked today like
part of why i wanted to do this and you
said a lot of things i didn't know you
were going to say but but i think are
important around
you know the people who work
hard right and again it's a physical
labor type heart it's not oh i spend a
lot of hours but
actual physical labor this idea of when
i get home i'm tired right
you are trading your time four dollars
and uh
there's a lot of people who spend their
entire lives doing that
and they never realize the things you've
learned in the last two years right
but as soon as you kind of get your mind
open to this stuff
you immediately realize hey there's
another path right i can use where
i am today to drive revenue or income
for myself i can then
take that income i can protect it i can
grow it i can do things so that i can
put myself in a position to
spend more time with my family and do
the things i want to do and i think
that story doesn't get told enough uh
whether it's in canada the united states
or elsewhere
of you know the knowledge is such a
great equalizer right
you have the same knowledge that
somebody sitting
in a white-collar job inside of an
investment firm has and when you get on
that level playing field
the things that you can do uh are
frankly
generation defining for you and your
family right because if you know this
stuff well guess what you're going to
teach your daughters this
and if they know they're going to teach
their kid children and so what you can
literally do is kind of change the
inflection point of an entire
uh kind of lineage of a family all
because of knowledge and i think that's
the beauty of
kind of your story and many other people
like you is that
once you have the curiosity and kind of
self-starter attitude of like i want to
get this information
you don't got to be a genius right
you're not a genius i'm not a genius
there's like five geniuses in the world
right they're all billionaires because
they're because they're geniuses right
yeah
but but uh for everybody else like you
just work hard and you try to do the
things that you think are the right
things to do
and when you're armed with the right
knowledge then you end up being
successful it's
it's put a light at the end of the
tunnel for me and that's
that's huge that's everything um i i
i don't know if i heard this somewhere
but uh i was thinking about it
i'm not trying to take over the world
i'm trying to take good care of my
family
and and that that's just the bottom line
um and i want to be happy and
uh be able to enjoy it while it's
happening
i love that uh we're gonna end on that
because that is the most powerful best
quote that might have ever been said on
this podcast
uh before i let you go where can we send
people now
we talked before uh for 99 of people who
are listening
they are not uh kind of geographically
close to you so for your business
they're going to be kind of out of reach
but
i know that we've got some listeners
that uh are in your neck of the woods in
canada
so just talk a little bit about kind of
where people can go find out more about
your business and then kind of what
areas you service in case anyone
listening is in that area
sure so um i'm most active on instagram
um it's a great space for contractors to
share their work
so my my contact on there is at
mac period the period builder
um macro yeah growing up with
again with kids having that uh bob the
builder
uh thing falling all around all the time
so
um yeah it's mac with a k um
like i say it's just a great community
twitter
i'm not like i say if you read my my bio
it says don't mind me i don't know
anything
and uh yeah yeah i
i service uh i'll service the vancouver
island but basically the uh
the northern vancouver island is uh my
home and and where i like to try and
stay i've been able to
stay busy here so i'm likely to stick
around here
that's awesome man so mac the mac dot
the dot
builder on instagram absolutely yeah
all right mackenzie listen thank you so
much for doing this i think people are
really gonna enjoy this
and uh we'll do it again in the future
when uh when you kind of keep going
thanks man again thank you so much this
has been awesome